The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
STEFANIE TELLEX: So today I'm
going to talk about human robot
collaboration.
How can we make robots that can
work together with people just
as if they were
another person and try
to achieve this kind of fluid
dynamic that people have
when they work together?
These are my human
collaborators.
This work is done by a lot
of collaborative students
and postdocs.
So we're really in an
exciting time in robotics
because robots are becoming
more and more capable
and they're able to operate
in one structured environment.
Russ gave a great
talk about Atlas
doing things like driving
a car and opening doors.
This is another robot
that I've worked with.
A robotic forklift that can
drive around autonomously
in warehouse environments.
It can detect where pallets are,
track people, pick things up,
put things down.
And it's designed to do
this in collaboration
with people who also
share the environment.
There's robots that can
assemble IKEA furniture.
This was Ross Knepper
and Daniela Rus
at MIT that I worked
with to do this.
So they made this team of
robots that can autonomously
assemble tables and chairs
that are produced by IKEA.
And what would be
nice is if people
can work with these robots.
Sometimes they
encounter failures,
and the person might
be able to intervene
in a way that enables the
robot to recover from failure.
And kind of the dream
is robots that operate
in household environments.
So this is my son when he was
about nine months old when we
shot this picture with a PR2.
You'd really like
to imagine a robot--
Rosie the robot from the
Jetsons that lives in your house
with you and helps you
in all kinds of ways.
Anything from doing the laundry
to cleaning up your room,
emptying the dishwasher,
helping you cook.
And this could have
applications for people
in all aspects of life.
Elders, people who are
disabled, or even people
who are really busy and
don't feel like doing
all the chores in their house.
So the aim of my
research program
is to enable humans and
robots to collaborate together
on complex tasks.
And I'm going to talk about
the three big problems
that I think we need to
solve to make this happen.
So the first problem
is that you need
to be able to have a robot that
can robustly perform actions
in real-world environments.
And we're seeing more and
more progress in this area,
but the house is kind of
like this grand challenge.
And John was talking about
kind of all these edge cases.
So I'm going to talk
about an approach
that we're taking
to try to increase
the robustness and also
the diversity of actions
that a robot can take in
a real-world environment
by taking an
instance-based approach.
Next, you need robots
that can carry out
complex sequences of actions.
So they need to be able
to plan in really, really
large combinatorial
state-action spaces.
There might be hundreds or
thousands of objects in a home
that a robot might
need to manipulate
and depending on whether
the person is doing laundry
or they cooking broccoli
or are they making dessert.
The set of objects
that are relevant that
are useful that the robot needs
to worry about in order to help
the person is wildly different.
So we need new algorithms for
planning in this really large
state- action space.
And finally, the
robot needs to be
able to figure out what people
want in the first place.
So people communicate
using language, gesture,
but also just by walking
around the environment
and doing things that you can
infer something about what
their intentions are.
And critically, when people
communicate with other people,
it's not an open loop
kind of communication.
It's not like you send a
message and then close your eyes
and hope for the best.
People, when you're
talking with other people,
engage in a closed
loop dialogue.
There's feedback going on
in both directions that
acts to detect and reduce
errors in the communication.
And this is a critical
thing for robots
to exploit because robots
have a lot more problems
than people do in terms of
perceiving the environment
and acting in the environment.
So it's really important
that we establish
some kind of feedback loop
between the human and the robot
so that the robot can
infer what the person wants
and carry out helpful actions.
So the three parts
of the talk are
going to be about each
of these three things.
So this is my dad's
pantry in a home.
And it's kind of like John's
pictures of the Google car.
Most robots can't pick up
most objects most of the time.
It's really hard to imagine
a robot doing anything
with a scene like this one.
There was just the
Amazon picking challenge
and the team that won
used a vacuum cleaner,
not a gripper to
pick up the objects.
They literally sucked the
things up in the gripper
and then turned the vacuum
cleaner off to put things down.
And the Amazon challenge
had much, much sparser stuff
on the shelves.
We'd really like to be able
to do things like this.
And what we're
doing now I'm really
going to focus on a sub-problem,
which is object delivery.
So from my perspective, I
think a really important sort
of baseline capability
for a manipulator robot
is to be able to pick something
up and move it somewhere else.
We'd obviously love
a lot more things.
We're also talking about
buttoning shirts in the car.
And you can go on with
all the things you
might want your robot to do.
But at least, we'd like to
be able to do pick and place.
Pick it up and put it down.
So maybe you are in a
factory delivering tools,
or maybe you're in the
kitchen delivering stuff
like ingredients or
cooking utensils.
So to do pick and place in
response to natural language
commands-- so let's say, hand
me the knife or something--
you need to know a few
things about the object.
First of all, you need to
be able to know what it is.
If they said, hand
me the ruler, you
need to be able to know whether
or not this object is a ruler.
So some kind of label
that can hook up
to some kind of language model.
Second, you have to know where
the object is in the world
because you're going
to actually move
your grippers and your
object and yourself
through 3D space in order
to find that object.
So here I'm going to highlight
the pixels of the object.
But you have to
register those pixels
into some kind of
coordinate system
that lets you move your
gripper over to that object.
And then third, you have
to know where on that
object are you going
to put your gripper.
So in the case of this
ruler, it's pretty heavy,
and it's this funny
shape that doesn't
have very good friction.
So for our robot, the
best place to pick it up
is in the middle of the object.
And there might be more
than one good place,
and it might depend
on the gripper.
And different objects
might have complex things
going on that change where the
right place is to pick it up.
So conventional
approaches to this problem
fall into two
general categories.
The first category, the
first high-level approach
is what I'm going to call
category-based grasping.
This is the dream.
So the dream is that you
walk up to your robot,
you hand it an object that
it's never seen before,
and the robot infers all
three of those things, what
it is, where it is, and
where to put the gripper.
And there's a line of
work that does this.
So this is one paper
from Ashutosh Saxena,
and there's a bunch of others.
The problem is that it
doesn't work well enough.
We are not at the accuracy
rates that sort of John
was alluding to that
we need for driving.
So in Ashutosh's paper, I
think they got 70% or 80%
pick success rate on their
particular test set at doing
category-based grasping.
And I think that
you're going to have
to expect that to fall if
you actually give it a wider
array of objects in the home.
And even if it doesn't
fall, 80% means
it's dropping things 20% of the
time, and that's not so good.
The second approach is
instance-based grasping.
So I was talking to Eric
Sudderth in my department
who does machine
learning, he said,
instant recognition is a solved
problem in computer vision.
So instant recognition is I give
you a training set of the slide
flipper, lots of images
of it, and then your job
given a new picture is to draw
a little box around the slide
flipper.
This is considered a solved
problem in computer vision.
There is a data
set and a corpus,
and the performance
maxed out, and people
have stopped working on it.
And a lot of the
work in robotics
uses this kind of approach.
We were talking about you have
some kind of geometric model.
That's the instance-based model.
These models can take a
lot of different forms.
They can be an image or a
3D model or whatever it is.
The problem is, where
do you get that model.
So if I am in my house
and there is thousands
of different objects,
you're not going
to have the 3D model most
likely for the object
that you want to pick up
right now for the person.
So there's this
sort of data grab.
But if you do have the model, it
can be really, really accurate
because you can know
a lot about the object
that you're trying to pick up.
So the contribution
of our approach
is to try to bridge these
two by enabling a robot
to get the accuracy of the
instance-based approach
by autonomously
collecting its own data
that it needs in order to
robustly manipulate objects.
So we're going to
get the accuracy
of instance-based approach
and the generality of category
at the cost of not human
time, but robot time
to build this model.
So here's what it looks
like on our Baxter.
It's going to make
a point cloud.
This is showing-- it's got a one
pixel connect in its gripper.
So you're seeing it doing
a sort of raster scan.
This is sped up to
get a point cloud.
Now it's taking
images of the object.
So it's got an RGB
camera in its wrist.
It's taking pictures
of the object
from lots of different
perspectives.
So the data looks like this.
You segment out the object
from the background.
You get lots and lots
and lots of images.
You do completely
standard computer vision
stuff, SIFT and kNN, to make
a detector out of this data.
You can get a point cloud.
This is the point
cloud looks like
at one-centimeter resolution.
And after we do this, we're
able to pick up lots of stuff.
So this is showing our robot--
these two objects,
localizing the object
and picking things up.
It's going to pick up the egg.
And that's a practice EpiPen.
There's a little shake to make
sure it's got a good grasp.
Now this works on
a lot of objects,
so let's see how it
does on the ruler.
So the way that the
system is working
is it's using the
point cloud to infer
where to grasp the object.
But we don't really have a
model of physics or friction
or slippage.
So it infers a
grasp near the end
because it fits in the gripper.
It kind of looks like
it's going to work.
And it does fit in the
gripper, but when we go and do
that shake, what's
going to happen
is it's going to pop
right out of the gripper
because it's got this
relatively low friction.
There it goes and falls out.
So that's bad, right?
We don't really like it
when our robots drop things.
So before training, what happens
is it falls out of the gripper.
In the case of
the ruler, there's
sort of physics going on, right?
Things are slipping
out, and maybe we
should be doing
physical reasoning.
I think we should be
doing physical reasoning.
I won't say "maybe" about that.
But we're not
doing it right now.
And there's lots of
reasons things could fail.
So in other problematic
objects, this
is one of those salt shakers.
It's got black handles that are
great for our robot to pick up,
but they're black, so
they absorb the IR light,
so we can't see them.
So we can't figure out that
we're supposed to grab there.
That round bulb looks awesome.
It's transparent
though, so you get
all these weird reflections.
So the robots-- are
inference algorithms is like,
oh, that bulb, that's
where we should pick it up.
It doesn't fit in the gripper.
So it will very often
slip out of the gripper.
So what our approach to solve
this problem is, is we're
going to let the robot practice.
So we have-- I'm not going
to go through the algorithm,
but we have this unarmed
bandit algorithm that
lets us systematically decide
where we should pick objects
up.
You can give it a prior on
where you think good graphs are.
And you can use
whatever information
you want in that prior.
And if the prior was perfect,
this would be boring.
It would just work the first
time, and life would go on.
But if the prior's
wrong for any reason,
the robot will be able to detect
it and fix things up and learn
where the most reliable places
are to pick up those objects.
So here's an example
of what happens
when we use this algorithm.
We practice picking
up the ruler.
I forget how many times it had.
Maybe 20 on this
particular object.
One of the rifts
on the algorithm
is it decides when to stop.
So we go a maximum 50 picks.
But we might stop after
three if all three of them
work so that you can go on
to the next object to train.
So here it picks up in the
middle and does a nice shake.
OK, so what we're doing now is
scaling up this whole thing.
So this is showing our robot
practicing on lots and lots
of different objects.
A lot of them are toys.
My son likes to watch
this video because he
likes to see the robot
playing with all of his toys.
And I think playing
is actually--
I mean it's one of those
loaded cognitive science words,
but I think that's
an interesting way
to think about what the robots
are actually doing right now.
It's doing little
experiments trying
to pick up these objects
in different places
and recording where it works
and where it doesn't work.
So this is sort of
showing 16, 32, one
in each hand objects being
done in our initial evaluation.
And at the end of this,
basically, it works.
So this is all the
objects in our test set.
And before learning, we were
able to do with this proposal
system, which uses the steps
information, we get about 50%
pick success rate.
After learning,
they go up to 75%.
And the other really
cool thing is that this
is a bimodal distribution.
So it doesn't say 75% is
what you're going to get.
A lot of these objects worked
eight, nine out of 10 times
or 10 out of 10 times.
It goes from worst to best.
So the good stuff
is all over there,
and the hard stuff
is all over there.
A lot of other objects
were really hard.
So that garlic press I think
we picked it up one time.
It's really, really heavy,
so it slips out a lot.
That gyro-ball thing
has a lot of reflection,
so we had trouble
localizing it accurately.
So we picked it
up very few times.
I think everything
from about the EpiPen
over was eight out
of 10 or better.
So not only-- so there's a lot
of objects that we can pick up,
and we can know which
ones we can pick up.
And which ones we can't.
We are right now taking an
aggressively instance-based
approach.
And the reason that
we're doing that is I
think there's something
magic when the robot actually
picks something up.
So where I wanted to
start is let's cheat
in every way we can.
Let's completely
make a model that's
totally specific to
this particular object.
But the next step
that we're doing
is to try to scale
up this whole thing
and then start to think about
more general models to go back
to that dream of
category-based recognition.
So if you look at computer
vision success stories,
one of the things that makes
a lot of algorithms successful
is data sets.
And the size of those
data sets is immense.
A lot of the computer
vision data sets,
COCO DB from Microsoft,
have millions
of images, which are labeled
with where the object is.
But most of those
images are taken
by a human photographer
on your cell phone
or uploaded to Flicker.
Wherever they got them from.
And you get to see
each object once.
Maybe you see it twice
from one perspective
that a human carefully chose.
You don't get to play with it.
You don't get to manipulate it.
In robotics, there's some
data sets of object instances.
The largest ones have a
few hundred of objects.
So computer vision
people that I've
talked to they laugh at it
because it's just so much
smaller compared to the data
sets that we're working with.
I think it's also so
much smaller than what
a human child gets to play
with over the course of going
from zero to two years old.
I guess my son became a mobile
manipulator around a year later
around one and a half or so.
I'm not sure exactly when.
So one of my goals is to
scale up this whole thing
to change this data equation
to be more in our favor.
So there's about 300 of these--
this is the Baxter robot--
there's about 300 of them
that Rethink Robotics--
Rod Brooks-- so we were
talking about Rob Brooks
in the previous talk.
Rod founded this company
Rethink Robotics.
They've sold about 300 of
them to the robotics research
community.
That's a very high penetration
rate in robotics research.
Everybody has a Baxter or
a friend with a Baxter.
So we're starting something
which we're calling
the million object challenge.
And the goal is to enlist
all of those Baxters, which
are sitting around doing
nothing a lot of the time--
to change this data equation.
So what we're doing
is we're going
to try to get everybody
to scan objects for us,
so that we can get
models, perceptual models,
visual models, and also
manipulation experiences
with these objects to try to
train new and better category
models.
And I think even
existing algorithms
may work way better simply
because they have better data.
But I think it also
opens up the door
to thinking about better models
that we maybe couldn't even
think about before because
we just didn't have
the data to play with them.
So where we are right now
is we've installed our stack
at MIT on Daniela Rus's Baxter.
That's this one.
And we went down
to Yale a couple
of weeks ago to Scass's lab
and we have our software
on their Baxter.
We're going to Rethink tomorrow.
They're going to give us
three Baxters that we're going
to play with and install there.
And I have a verbal
yes from WPI.
And a few other people
have been like--
I pitched this at RSS.
So a lot of people have
said they were interested.
I don't know if they'll actually
translate to robot time.
And our goal is to get
about 500 or 1,000 objects
between these three sites.
Four sites I guess if
the WPI gets on board.
Four sites including us.
So Rethink, Yale, MIT and us.
And then do like a larger press
release about the project.
Advertise it, push over all
of our friends with Baxters
to help us scan.
And then have yearly scanathons
where you download the latest
software and then spend a
couple of days scanning objects
for the glory of
robotics or something.
And really try to change this
data equation for the better,
so we can manipulate
lots of things.
So that's our plan
for making robots
that can robustly
perform actions
and real-world environments.
More generally, I imagine
like a mobile robot
walking around
your house at night
and scanning stuff
completely autonomously.
Taking these pictures, building
these models, hopefully,
not breaking too
much of your stuff.
And not only learning about your
particular house and the things
that are in it, but
also collecting data
that will enable other robots
to perform better over time.
All right, so that's our
attack on making robots
robustly perform actions
in real-world environments.
So the next problem that
I think is important
for language understanding
of human robot collaboration
is making robots to carry out
complex sequences of actions.
So for example, this
is this pantry again.
There might be hundreds
or thousands of objects
that the robot could
potentially manipulate.
And it might need
to do a sequence
of 10 or 20
manipulations in order
to solve a problem such
as clean up the kitchen
or put away the groceries.
For work that I had done in
the past on the forklift a lot
of the commands that
we studied and thought
about were the level
of abstraction of put
the pallet on the truck.
But one of our annotators--
we cleared the law of data
on Amazon Mechanical Turk.
And one of our annotators gave
us this problem that I never
forgot, which was how--
it was the actual
forklift operator
who worked in a
warehouse, and he
said if you paid me
extra money, I'll
tell you how to pick up a dime--
a dime, like a little coin
with a forklift.
Here's the instructions
that he eventually
without making us
pay him gave us
for how to solve this problem.
So it was raise the
forks 12 inches,
line it in front of the
dime, tilt it forward,
drive a little bit
over, you lower the fork
on top of the dime,
put it in reverse
and travel backward,
the dime kind
of flips up backwards
on top of the fork.
Maybe you know how
to drive a forklift,
but you can see how
that would work.
And if you did know how
to drive a forklift,
you can follow
those instructions
and have it happen.
But I knew that our system if
we gave it these commands, there
is no way that it would work.
It would completely fall apart.
And the reason that
it would fall apart
is that we gave the
robot a model of actions
at a different
level of abstraction
than this language is using.
We gave it a very high-level
of abstract actions,
like picking stuff up and moving
it into particular locations
and moving things down.
And if we gave it
these low-level actions
of like raising the
forks 12 inches,
the search steps that
would be required
to find a high-level thing like
put the pallet on the truck
would be prohibitively
expensive.
And I think if we want to
have human-- but the thing is
people don't like to stick at
any fixed level of abstraction.
People move up and
down the tree freely.
They give very high-level,
mid-level, low-level commands.
So I think we need new
planning algorithms that
support this kind of thing.
So to think about
this, we decided
to look at a version of
the problem in simulation.
The simulator that we chose
is a game called Minecraft.
Five minutes, OK.
So it's sort of this--
this is a picture from
a Minecraft world.
And we're trying to figure
out new planning algorithms.
So the problem here
is that the agent
needs to cross the trench.
So he needs to make a bridge
to get across the trench.
So it's got some blocks
that he can manipulate.
And you have this
combinatorial explosion
of where the blocks can go.
They can go anywhere.
So in a naive
algorithm, we'll spend
a lot of time putting
the blocks everywhere,
which doesn't
really make progress
towards solving a problem.
Whereas what you
really need to do
is focus on putting these
blocks actually in the trench
in order to solve the problem.
Of course, on a
different day, you
might be asked to make
a tower or make a castle
or make a staircase,
and then these
might be good things to do.
So you don't just throw
out those actions.
You want to have them
both and figure out
what to do based on
your high-level goal.
So we have some work about
learning how to do this.
So we have an agent
that practices
solving small Minecraft
problems and then learns
how to solve bigger
problems from experience.
This is showing transferring
this from small problems
to big problems in a decision
theoretic framework, an MDP
framework.
And we've just released
a couple of weeks
ago a mod for Minecraft,
the game called BurlapCraft.
BURLAP is our reinforcement
learning and planning framework
that James MacGlashan
and Michael
Littman developed in Java.
So you can run BURLAP
inside the Minecraft JVM.
Get the state of the
real Minecraft world.
Make small toy
problems if you want.
Or let your agent
go in the real thing
and explore the whole space
of possible Minecraft spaces
if you're interested
in that simulation.
OK, I'm almost out
of time, so I'm not
going to go too much into
robots coordinating with people.
But maybe I will show some of
the videos about this work.
The idea is that a lot of the
previous work and language
understanding shows people
works in batch mode.
So the robot does something--
the person says something,
the robot thinks
for a long time,
and then the robot
does something.
Hopefully, the right thing.
And as I said before, this
is not how people will work.
So we're working on new
models that enable the robot--
this is a graphical
model that shows how it--
talking about it in the car.
What happens, it incrementally
interprets language and gesture
updating at very
high frequencies.
So this is showing the
belief about which objects
the person wants, updating
from their language and gesture
in an animated
kind of way, right?
Like, it's updating at 14 Hertz.
So the idea is that the
robot has the information.
This is its own language.
I would like a bowl.
Both bowls go up.
That one he points and then
the one that he's pointing at
goes up.
So the robot knows
very, very quickly,
every time we get a new word
from [INAUDIBLE] condition,
every time we get a new
observation from the gesture
system, we update our belief.
And just a couple of weeks ago,
we had our first pilot results
showing that we can use this
information to enable the robot
to produce real-time feedback
that increases the human's
accuracy at getting the robot
to select the right object.
This is some
quantitative results.
I'll skip it.
OK, so that's the
three main thrusts
that I'm working on
in my research group.
Trying to make robots that
can robustly perform actions
in real-world environments.
Thinking about planning in
a really large state action
spaces that result when you have
a capable and powerful robot.
And then thinking about how you
can make the robot coordinate
with people so that
they can figure out
what to do in these really
large state actions spaces.
Thank you.